this is Startalk so Elaine when we think
of a voice it's that you know there's at
your chest cavity there's vibrating
vocal cords as your tongue lips so when
you think of music in your head are you
thinking about all the things that go
into what makes the vibration is that
that's part of what you have to study to
understand music right yep musicians
definitely we study that but actually it
depends on what instrument you're really
focused on you know like voice you got
the whole voice yeah you yourself are
the instrument so you've naturally
create these vibrations you know from
speaking anyway so as a pianist though
as you know we're thinking about making
the tones and not necessarily creating
that all right so the piano person
doesn't have to worry about air supply
there's so many other instruments do
right yeah sure yes it's true but we do
have to put breath in the music though
you know so you put it in with your body
as you phrase with the body
really yes whereas singers will take you
know in or any wind instrument you
breathe you breathe in through your nose
you know goes to your diary so know what
you say you telling me the piano player
is breathing into the music oh oh
absolutely
that's phrasing that's all that's what
it's all about so the phrasing comes
from the body movements is that what
you're saying I'm not necessarily I mean
if you force that in there it's false
but but you know music unfolds in
phrases okay in segments like sentences
can't I just copy you and turn you into
a piano roll and the piano roll ain't
breathing it's just that's why it
doesn't sound it doesn't it sounds
artificial there's music that you hear
digitally you know you you can hear it
online and there's something wrong so
there's no life in it exactly tell when
there's a human being behind it with a
voice you can you know you sometimes can
hear the inhalation you know with the
piano you have to breathe as you play
and you move in your your whole body it
goes into it so tell me about the the
the the the registers is that what it's
called the range low
medium-high I mean people a voice yeah
yeah for voice register yes yes oh sure
yeah you know bass baritone he's lyric
baritone which implies it's a little bit
higher you have tenor you have a contra
tenor then comes alto metal soprano
soprano and I lost my Symphony yeah so
you know as far as determining what your
ranges is you know you you just can just
say well how low can I sing and and how
high cuz pre-puberty I think there's a
there's no difference between the boy
the girl voice and the boy voice well I
know I sang first soprano in choir so
for very long recently yeah I thank for
soprano it was it was a church choir and
for a Grace Episcopal Church and it was
wonderful I replaced a young girl named
Lisa had moved to Alto
because she had like women go through
puberty their voices changed too oh yeah
absolutely you were still in there yes
okay and so I was teased quite a bit
because I sang the first soprano parts
and you know and then of course I went
to the change and I got my first monthly
well they probably decide we're sad to
lose your you know your boy voice
because even if you did replace a female
girl voice it's so different the tambour
of your voice is different this is
Startalk